[Music]
fire base summit wrapped up a few days
ago and although I wasn't able to make
it in person they did announce a bunch
of cool new features the feature that is
most exciting to me is the local
emulator for Fighter Store and the
real-time database the emulators allow
you to run an instance of your database
locally meaning you can build up a test
suite around your security rules
this not only speeds up development time
but it also increases the integrity of
your back-end security in today's video
you'll learn how to set up the emulator
and build out a full test suite using
chests if you're new here like and
subscribe and make sure to grab the full
source code from angular firebase comm
now before we get going with the
emulator I'd also like to point out that
firebase announced a new project
management API this API makes it
possible for apps to manage firebase
projects of other users for example you
can now deploy your firebase projects
directly from stack blitz or glitch but
the more exciting thing going on there
is that you can use this project
management API to build your own apps
that do the exact same thing so let me
know in the comments if you want to see
that covered in a future video so now
let's get started talking about the
emulator the emulator just runs fire
store or the real-time database locally
on your machine this means you can now
simulate interaction with the database
without actually having to run it in the
cloud this makes it so much easier to be
confident that a complex set of security
rules are working the way that they
should I'm gonna go ahead and set this
project up with just a vanilla
JavaScript and just as the testing
library the reason I choose jest is
because it's very developer friendly and
also really good at testing asynchronous
code to start testing your rules in
isolation
I'd recommend starting from a brand new
directory and then install the latest
version of firebase tools once that's
done you can run firebase init fire
store and that will pull in your
existing security rules from whichever
project you select from there you can
run NPM in it to set up a package.json
in this folder then after that we can
install our testing utilities which
include at firebase testing and jest
then we'll give us a directory structure
that looks something like this I've also
created a spec folder that includes our
testing files all of our testing code
will be written there and then the thing
we're actually testing is this firestore
rules file if you're not already
familiar with fire store security rules
I recommend checking out episode 92
where I teach you all about rules and
how to
hack a firebase app and one additional
pro tip I have for you here is to
install the firebase security rules
plugin for BS code to get syntax
highlighting and autocomplete while you
write out your rules now there are a few
additional steps to install the emulator
you can do it directly from the command
line with the instructions here or you
can install the Java jar file directly
you'll probably wanna go at the
command-line option but in either case
you need to have Java installed on your
system
if Java is not already on your system
head over to there super-modern website
and get it installed today now I want to
show you what a basic test run will look
like we have two terminal windows setup
here on the left side we'll go ahead and
run the emulator which we can do with
firebase serve only fire store that will
run the local emulator in the background
you really just need to keep this in
mind for debugging if it's not behaving
the way you expect then on the right
side we can run the Jess command to run
our actual specs now I've been working
with the emulator for a couple days now
and I want to start this video off by
giving you some helpers that will just
make your test easier to write and also
just to warn you we're going to be
writing a lot of async functions so if
you haven't seen the async/await video
make sure to check that out as well
the first helper function is called
setup and this will create an instance
of the emulated firestore database it
also has the option to take an auth
object which will create a fake user and
also mock data that will be written to
the database when it's initialized every
time you initialize a test database
you'll want to give it a unique project
ID you can do this easily by just making
your project ID a random number or a
date/time stamp from this point you'll
want to go ahead and call firebase
initialize test app it's important to
note that when you initialize the app
for the first time it will not have any
security rules applied to it this is
actually very useful because we can see
the database with some mock data before
the rules are applied to it and you can
also provide a user context which would
just be an object with a user ID that
you could then use to test your rules
the way that I see the database is I
provide a data object where every key in
that object is the path to the document
and then the value is the data that we
want to write to the database this makes
it really easy to see the database
because we can just loop over the keys
and that object and then write the data
to their corresponding paths now that we
have the mock data seated in the
database we'll go ahead and
applied the security rules that can be
done by calling load firestore rules and
then we'll want to use the file system
to point to the actual raw rules file
and finally we'll return the actual
database instance from this method so we
can use it throughout our specs so now
that we have our setup done I'm also
going to export a function called
teardown which will just look for all
the firebase apps that were created on
this test run and then delete them once
the tests are finished so those should
make your life a lot easier now let's
look at how we can use them in an actual
test you typically want your database to
be secure by default which means that
you'll have allow read and write if
false at the very top level of the
database this means that all paths are
locked down by default unless you
specifically allow access to them let's
go ahead and test that this actually
works by first importing our setup and
teardown methods then firebase provides
us with two tests and utilities that we
can use to determine whether or not an
operation was successful or failed the
first thing we'll do is describe our
test suite which is just our database
rules then we'll declare the database as
a global variable that we can reuse
throughout the tests then we can use the
before all hook to define the database
with our setup method that we define in
the helpers file the thing we actually
want to test here is that our database
is secure by default so if we try to
read or write to any random collection
it should give us a permission denied
error and after all the test run will
also want to run our teardown method to
delete those app instances ingest you
can write a test by using the test
method and then describing what you're
testing in this case the operation
should fail when reading or writing to
an unauthorized collection so there are
a few different ways to write your
actual tests and this really just boils
down to the developers preference I
would definitely recommend making this
an async function if you like readable
code then the firebase assertion helpers
will take a promise as their argument
such as a document read if the read is
blocked by security rules in this case
then this promise will resolve but if
the reads successful then the promise
will be rejected all we have to do is
add the result to an expectation and our
first test is completed if you want to
make your code even more concise you can
actually just inline the await statement
directly in the expectation that'll give
you a nice and concise single line test
but these get very hard to read as your
tests get more complex
to give you one more option here which
is slightly more advanced and that's
creating your own custom matcher with
just what we can do is pass our read
directly into expect and then we can
resolve it as a custom matcher that will
either be to deny or to allow basically
every test that you write will be
checking whether or not a document
operation was denied or allowed so
having a custom matcher here is super
useful because it not only keeps you our
code concise but also readable let's go
ahead and switch back to our helpers
file and that I'm going to write expect
extend and provide it with an async
function called to allow the X argument
to this function is whatever you pass to
the expectation which should be a
firebase promise for example reading or
writing a certain path in the database
we will try to resolve the promise and
if it resolves we know that the test
should pass otherwise we're going to
have the test fail then from the custom
assertion you just need to return an
object that has a pass value which
should either be true or false and then
a message which is a function that
returns a string and keep in mind that
this message will only be shown if the
test fails so now we have a match for
that will fail if the database reader
right is blocked by firebase rules then
we'll also want to create an inverse
matcher to check if a firebase rule is
allowed when it should have been denied
so we'll say to deny and just check with
the assert fails method from firebase
you can use whatever testing methods you
want but I'll be using my custom
matchers throughout this lesson now I'm
going to open up our comment spec which
defines the rules for our comments
collection and in this particular app a
user needs to be authenticated to view
comments and when writing a comment it
must have a user ID that matches the
auth user ID if we look at the actual
rules logic you can see we're allowing
reads if the request auth UID does not
equal null and then we're allowing
rights if the UID is equal to the
request resource data user ID in other
words the document that the user is
trying to write to the database has the
same user ID as the actual
authentication object user ID ensuring
that these rights fail is pretty easy
all we have to do is set up the database
with an authenticated user and then we
can make a reference to our collection
and expect that that read or write is
denied but it's even more important that
we verify that the
operations are allowed when the user has
the proper credentials so this time
we'll set up our database with an auth
object that has a user ID and an email
address this time we'll expect the reads
to be allowed because we have a user
that's logged in I currently have my
test running in watch mode so you can
see here if we switch out the matcher
that the test will fail if we expect
this to be denied
now when writing to the database we'll
expect the right to succeed if the user
sends an object that has the
corresponding user ID so we would expect
this add operation to be allowed because
it has the same user ID as the off.you
ID then we can add another line here
that tries to add an item to the
database with a different user ID and
we'll expect that one to be denied so
that's how you test basic user
authentication logic in the next step
we'll look at how we can see the
database with mock data and handle
things like role based access control
now going back to our rules I have a
function here called get user data which
will read a document in the users
collection in the database so in order
to test this function will need to first
seed our database with some mock data
for the user then in that document we'll
have an object that has different roles
that the user can have such as an admin
role so now in our projects collection
we can see if the user has this admin
role and if they do we'll allow access
and then we could also do the inverse of
this and have the actual document itself
defined who has access in that case we
would be building an access control list
and we would check if the resource data
has any members with the current auth
user ID so essentially we have one rule
here that defines logic for role based
access control and also access control
lists the last thing I want to show you
is how to set up the mock data we
defined this earlier in the setup
function and we're going to create an
object where each key in that object is
the path to the document then its value
is the object that we want to write to
the database for example we might have a
user that has an admin role or you might
have a project that has an access
control list with a certain user in it
now when we set up the database we can
add the first argument as the
authenticated user and in the second
argument will be the mock data object
that will automatically see our database
with the required data and then we can
test it in relation to the authenticated
user then the remaining test will look
basically this
they've looked in the past we'll try to
do a read or write operation and then
see if it's denied or allowed so just to
wrap things up writing solid security
rules is essential to securing your
firebase app I am super excited about
the emulator because it makes testing
rules much easier and reliable
especially when you're dealing with a
big complex app I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap the video up there if it helped you
like and subscribe and if you want to
take your development to the next level
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to all kinds of exclusive resources
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon